la poêle s'est terminée en ce début des
vacances de toussaint la première
destination à l'étranger choisi par les
français et la tunisie une destination
qui commence à être choisi pour d'autres
raisons que le soleil en effet la
chirurgie esthétique qui est pratiqué à
moindres coûts qu'en france et c'est par
internet qu'une agence de voyages
proposent des forfaits reportage
florence bukiya abdel juillet à
l'aéroport de tunis chaque jour les
tours opérators accueille des dizaines
de touristes mais la responsable de
cette agence attend une seule personne
stéphane ces prêts ni n'est pas une
cliente comme les autres elle vient
faire du tourisme esthétique plus
exactement se faire refaire les seins
qu'elle estime trop petit cet hôtel dans
lequel elle va séjourner plusieurs jours
la clinique le chirurgien qui va
l'opérer
elle ne les connaît que par internet et
téléphone alors pourquoi venir jusqu'ici
parce que ça coûte des 1400 euros au
lieu de 5000 en france l'opération la
prise en charge l'accueil tout un taux
de change très favorable en euros des
infirmières payer quatre fois moins
qu'en france
voilà la recette tunisienne bonjour
après une nuit de repos stéphanie fait
la connaissance de son médecin
j'ai compris votre gourmand vous êtes
ici pour une augmentation mammaire est
donc il s'agit de pose de prothèses
mammaires je rentrais prothèse décès là
je pense c'est bon la 6e' sitruk c'est
c'est un cas de plus le lendemain juste
avant l'anesthésié
le chirurgien explique précisément à la
patiente comment il va procéder en
contre ça n'arrive que jusque-là être
obligé de mettre la prothèse qu'en
dessous du muscle pectoral
le dr chaibi a été formé aux états unis
cette opération il la facture à l'
agence de voyages qui lui a confié la
patiente est selon lui les françaises ne
court pas plus de risque à être opérer
ici plutôt que dans leur pays dans la
mesure où elles sont opérés
pour des personnes qui ont été formés en
france ou aux états unis ou même ici
elles sont opérés de la même manière
techniquement parlant
mais pour les patientes étrangères je
pense qu'on est peut-être encore plus
diligent car celles qui arrivent de loin
viennent souvent seul il faut donc aussi
assurer leur bien-être
après l'opération trois jours plus tard
stéphanie passe la visite de contrôle et
découvre sa nouvelle poitrine
là je suis très contente c'est très joli
l'agencé statique à tour créé en janvier
dernier a déjà accueilli 360 patients
français suisse et canadien
en tunisie le tourisme esthétique
démarre très fort